e
e e
you know how the game works when the
Music Stops please find a seat
which I think
we did they put you in the wrong
spot well preferred
well that's what my wife says but I
refuse to
exercise call to order the meeting of
the Health and Human Services oversight
committee for Friday May 24th
2024 and would the clerk please call the
role representative Pearson
yeah representative McDonald
excused representative Weber here
representative Edwards here repres
representative King here representative
Merchant here representative Murphy here
Senator gray
coming Senator Rosenwald
excused and Senator
avard no
idea thank you please look at the
minutes for our last
meeting we've all gotten these ahead of
time
uh one correction I will make in terms
of uh attendance present um McDonald is
a Scottish McDonald not an Irish
McDonald so it's
Mac any
other additions Corrections
omissions I'll second that I also like
to recognize after doing the minutes I
want to commend uh
representative King for all the work you
put into in the minutes in the past
thank you I I appreciate that but I also
want to uh recognize that uh my front
and back is a poultry attempt at minutes
after I've seen representative Weber and
representative merchant do their version
thank you representative Weber's minutes
are almost a Verbatim yeah it's
wonderful any other Corrections
additions omissions
hearing none um all in favor of
accepting the minutes moved in second
with one correction to a name I I
opposed yep because you weren't at the
meeting we have had the request from uh
representative
Edwards if it is possible for us to move
this meeting permanently to 1 in the
afternoon off
of most of the time the fourth Friday at
10:00 a.m. occasionally shifted to the
third uh Friday at 1 p.m. and um just
have a brief discussion as to whether
moving from 10: to 1 on a
Friday is possible for
everyone Mr chair yes from
Weber you can make it work
Dr
Murphy would you care to
elaborate all that effort I poured into
getting to know
you I was ceasing on the probably and
hoping that there was hope there is hope
is There's Hope but but is there hope
that you're going to run is always do
you need $2 for the
fee beautiful day outside you're wasting
a lot of time
on well since you said that with a smile
um representative Merchant possible for
you it it's possible I have
a appreciation for Friday afternoons to
not tie them up um think we're getting
into the summer months I would like to
keep them as free as possible so I would
lean more towards very free in July and
August
thank you and even end the all be much
appreciated okay representative Senator
rosenal told me that would not work for
her um honestly for myself this is my
day off and I can rationalize being here
and leaving at noon but being here and
leaving it free is problematic for
me
um all right we'll just we'll percolate
on this representative Edwards so so so
obious thank you Mr chair so obviously
I'm in favor of moving this to the uh
afternoon uh I have a a an ongoing
conflict between the governor's
Commission on alcohol and drug misuse
and this and they're both very important
I think they're both very synergistic
and and I would love to be able to do
both um and I'm just not doing either
very well because of the conflict I it's
also my understanding I didn't speak for
the Department for a second that the
that the commiss commissioner May
benefit from having this move to the
afternoon as well do you do you want to
nod or shake your
head
oh all right and we we can serve
cocktails too
uh you're making it easier for me you
know Des Merchant thank you Mr chair um
is it always have to be in the fourth
Friday
no it doesn't have to be on the fourth
so representative Edwards with moving it
to a different Friday of the month yes
sure it would that would do it for me
representative Weber oh I'm I'm so sorry
to answer just to finish the answer of
the question Friday's mornings are
typically fiscal committee so would
probably uh run into yet a different
conflict with my fiscal committee
obligations but does that mean Friday
mornings but C every single Friday
morning no it's like every other I don't
know the we moved to the fourth to avoid
the fiscal okay we moving to the second
avoid fiscal I don't know because I'm
not on fiscal probably I can verify that
okay um let's Mr chair yes and also in
regards to the commissioner whether that
would help her with her conflicts as
well going to the second Friday of the
month I
always that's
fair representative Weber before we
spend too much time on this negotiation
which could be done by email right um
I'm going to point out that if we're not
here in July and August that leaves us
SE September and October before we are
reorganized and so all bets may be off
because everything may be moving to
different
times stay tuned thank
you DHHS Commissioners update
commissioner Lori
Weaver good morning
I did give a handout to uh each of you
it's the multicolored
multi-paged uh handout that says Mission
zero uh mobilizing Collective action so
I I thought it would be appropriate to
uh have my update this morning really be
on what's going on with Mission zero we
did have a court deadline of May 17th uh
which was last Friday um
to uh for certain things to be reached
by them so I thought i' give would the
commission hold for a minute yes
representative
Weber oh sure the one that has lots of
colors uh oh how about this
one I I did put one
over I I put it over there I thought
maybe you were sitting over
there no not at all it's always good to
have not at all thank
you you I'm sorry no no worries I
thought you usually do sit over there so
when your stuff was over there I was
confused so I thought um just to give a
little bit of a of an overview um back
uh about a year ago early 23 um the
hospital Association filed an injunction
against the department for seizing its
property in the emergency departments um
and through the court um injunction it
was determined that um the department
had one year to come into compliance
with moving patients within 6 hours out
of the Ed um happening right around the
same time uh the department Was
preparing to launch what we call Mission
zero which is what you have in front of
you and the goal of mission zero really
is about um we call it zero because we
want our weight list to be zero um so
we're not the only state in the country
obviously facing these challenges but it
was our call to Collective action so we
have um actually for the last ye you
know I guess 13 14 months maybe more um
than working collaboratively with our
partners so the basic premise is it of U
reducing the Ed boarding is being able
to look at all points in the system so
if it's the point of entry if it's the
point of exit if it's the point of
transfer where can we be making um
changes and where can be be making a
difference so I just want to be clear so
the difference between the two was the
injunction was for the 6 hours and then
Ed boarding Mission Zer was to eliminate
Ed boarding um they obviously do connect
and relate to one another if you um flip
to the center you'll see there's two
pages of blue uh chart this is what is
detailing all of our progress in the
last year so for the last year I've had
to report to the judge on a regular
basis what we've been doing in the
department what difference we making so
I'm happy to to come to you today and
share that we actually are making an
impact and we actually are having a
difference so despite not hitting the um
6h hour mark uh on the on the dot we I
can tell you that we have reduced by 50%
uh the number of days of people sitting
in EDS so that's pretty significant when
we look at where we were where there was
times we would have about upwards of 50
people on a weight list for long
extended periods of time we now see our
weight list changing and fluctuating so
for example um on Monday every Monday
every day I look at the weight list but
on Monday it was 31 and you know you
sort of gasp it like 31 it was 7 on
Friday what happened this weekend um and
then as of yesterday it was back down to
seven sitting in Ed so we break down our
weight list in terms of actually sitting
in the Ed and then there's some other
like um conditional discharge um and
some Correctional settings but we're
really honing in on on that Ed so
through our Partnerships I'll tell you
it's been a year of partnership um and
collaboration with um our
Nami our National Alliance for mentally
ill uh our community mental health
centers and the hospital Association um
as well as um our emergency department
room staff and docs so it's it's really
bringing together all of the people that
impact the system to be able to make a
difference and I just want to walk you
through quickly I'm not going to read
all of these for you but I do want to
highlight a couple of them um if you
look at on the first blue page year if
you go three down it says care traffic
control this was uh an effort that took
quite a while to stand up in terms of
the infrastructure and the positions and
what have you but basically 247 uh 247
we have staff at New Hampshire hospital
ready to receive these referrals ready
to receive the ieas um so what H has
happened is we now have a system where
every day there's a huddle with the Eds
to look at who's in the queue what the
available resources are and then making
sure that people get to where they need
to be so there's active um engagement
and active movement so that's why you
can see a weight list maybe in the
morning maybe rather High by the end of
the day we're able to look at all of our
designated receiving facility beds and
be make sure that they're getting
utilized which was part of the problem
before is that we would have a bunch of
beds not not just New Hampshire hospital
we have those beds but elsewhere and
they weren't being utilized so now we
have full knowledge full visibility from
all of our EDS saying okay this is the
total number of beds this is the total
need for today and then making that work
so that's pretty significant um the
hospital Association has partnered with
us on doing some training so we're
everybody that touches it we've they've
done about four trainings already
several hundred people at at some of
them and they'll continue to do them so
that people understand how what that
system is and how to use it so we're
rather proud of that um just speaking
about beds for a a little bit we had the
infamous unit enf unit that took forever
to come online at New Hampshire hospital
due to construction challenges or curses
as I like to say um and we finally got a
eunit up which was bringing an
additional 12 beds back online at the
beginning of May so we went from 158
capacity to 170 and we have 14 beds left
to get online by the end of this
calendar year um so our New Hampshire
hospital has worked uh very creatively
to for Staffing um to be able to staff
that and that's what they'll continue to
do is that Focus for the remaining 14 um
as of yesterday I believe all parties
have agreed to and including the courts
to give the department an extension
until December 31st of this calendar
year to come closer or to to meet that
6-h hour deadline um I know we're going
to come closer I'm hoping to hit that uh
six hours by the end of this year we are
working on dashboards with all of our
partners to be able to put up so
everybody has the same data about what's
what's happening with our uh system and
who's in it and what the needs are there
is a lot of work going on around what a
the 6 hours itself you know why the 6
hours why is it not 12 hours why is it
18 hours and so there's there's a lot a
lot of hands in the pot working on that
um so yesterday's weight list was seven
uh and the kids was a little bit higher
Mission zero does not cover the kids as
of today it is our goal it is our
mission to be able to expand at some
point for the kids but the kids numbers
can fluctuate and most of the kids are
not iea so there's a little bit of a
difference there um if you flip to the
second page of the of the um diagram
here in terms of you'll see there's two
things I just want to highlight which is
sort of that that exit door of leaving
we uh have had
traditionally disposition issues or
challenges if you will with folks that
don't need Hospital level of care and
they're still residing within the
hospital because there isn't enough uh
resources of places for them to go
afterwards so we actually have uh two
two five bed programs that will be at
full occupancy by the end of June um and
then two additional five bed Properties
by the end of July uh Riverbend is work
uh working with us we just brought on 12
new specialty residential beds um and we
also have our path uh program as well
that was transitioned over to NFI so
that that I highlight that that because
that's bringing forth um more resources
for that um exiting if you will and then
I think one of things that we're really
happy about is our landlord incentive
program which uh we actually uh have
patients unfortunately that have been in
the hospital for years right and it's
really hard to leave so really working
with landlords in terms of being able to
provide uh housing um but housing that
comes with support so if there's any um
consequences from any of
former patients living that they would
have resources available to maybe
address what some of those consequences
would be or even uh the help to be able
to have folks successfully stay where
they land so it it is our goal to have
25 patients moved in by the end of this
year um and I know some have already
moved
in I'll stop there because it looks like
you might have a question um one
facility I don't see mentioned here is
Hamstead Hospital how does that figure
not the new DCF building but the
existing Hamet hospital so Mission zero
doesn't apply to kids right now Mission
zero is adult Focus based on um Ed
boarding for adults yeah representative
Weber thank you very much and thank you
for that report um could you I have a
couple of just very specific questions
uh you said there were more kids than
seven as of yesterday waiting and I
understand that the the uh order doesn't
apply to them but how many were there
yesterday uh as of yesterday there were
10 on Monday there were
three okay and and as a followup if I
may um followup could you tell me about
the actual length of stays for adults in
EDS at the moment I know it's been
reduced but what having having heard
anecdotally of somebody who was there
for a week in December I just love to
know what the average day is now I I
couldn't rattle that off for you the top
of my head the dashboards that I I was
sharing that were about to share
publicly would have that and I can
follow up with you I just don't have
that in terms of because there's a lot
of beds so to average that out right I I
realize that it's a very moving Target
so thank you representative
Edwards thank you thank you Mr chair um
I I appreciate uh the work that's gone
into this commissioner um as I'm looking
at it I'm trying to imagine
the um sort of the the programmatic
management challenges and the financial
um estimation challenges associated with
having a program that sort of um you've
got a probably a central person or or
small staff that are worried about it
but the the ability to execute the
program is probably spread throughout
many components of the department many
other entities independent entities
throughout the state and so so the
program management and control aspect
seems inherently
challenging uh and the
financial uh estimation would therefore
be also hard to U predict I'm I I I I'm
curious how when this comes in to our
budget next year how we're going to know
how much money you need to support this
program because the the money will line
be lined up all over departments
everywhere
right yes so so so we've already spent
the money to stand up the position that
are specific to care traffic control
which is really like the main driver of
overseeing the system for the department
but that's that is in conjunction with
other
partners so that is all of the Eds are
working with us I I already have the
position stood up I I got I was able to
get that funding and those positions to
do that so that would be included in the
next year's budget for that not I'm not
necessarily looking to see additional
funding I think the Hope here is that we
we are able to discharge folks so that
we can keep people getting the needs of
services right so we have our Revenue
offsetting our expenses and then folks
being able to get to where they need so
in terms and I just want to say in terms
of program oversight one of the things
that didn't mention in here is we have a
steering committee and that steering
committee is the executive level
including myself of Nai the hospital
Association myself and Community Mental
Health Centers um and hospitals Who
oversee uh monthly what's happening with
all of these initiatives and where are
the numbers so there's a level of
accountability and oversight that isn't
just the Departments alone that would
continue so the parties to the suit are
at the table talking all the time or
regular
yeah we sit next to each other sometimes
too
yes so so I I I guess maybe I wasn't as
clear on the point I'm trying to make is
is I'm looking at this circle of six
initiatives each of these initiatives
has money associated with them on terms
of the current level and what the needed
required level is in the future so each
of these six are probably going to
percolate up into the through the budget
process in separate silos and and so I'm
just curious how we're going to see the
total cost of the total program so that
we can support a total program and not
just end up with six siloed questions
sure I mean the good news is that the
majority of these programs are federally
funded there's Federal money for that
and using very little general fund for
that other than our
staffing
so I I'm I'm not I'm not necessarily
connecting with what what you're I I'll
I'll leave it I'll I'll try to talk to
Nathan
okay anyone else for the commissioner on
this subject representative
Murphy thank you thank you for this
report very it's very helpful and for
one who had seen so many people staying
in the emergency room overnight I'm very
happy that the number is seven right now
my question is is the Huddle that you
referenced done at each hospital or is
it done
centrally um at your department and also
you mentioned resources does that impact
where some of these folks can go if they
have resources or
not so I have a question on your second
question but I'll answer your first
question first um the Huddle is
comprised of all of the hospitals that
have designated receiving facility beds
um there's quite a few in addition
addition to New Hampshire hospital that
are out there so that those huddles are
with those beds where we would Place
involuntary patients so it's receiving
people in a zoom type call that looks at
each day basically yeah so we're
actually have docs and and nurses on the
on the call uh AP uh psychiatric nurses
as well on the call with our staff yes
and then the second question was
resources um you mentioned resources
does that impact where some of these
folks can
go resources can be more specific in
terms of what I don't know you mentioned
you know you look at resources in the
huddles you look at resources the
numbers Etc in the question was is it
the resources of the patient or the
resources of facility that receiving the
patient It's usually the resources I
mean it's both right you're assessing a
patients needs and then you're looking
at what resources that you have within
those involuntary beds within the state
so sometimes you'll have somebody that
comes into a hospital that wants to be
served in that community area but
there's a bed available somewhere else
and so it's really working with is that
going to be an okay solution for that um
person to be transferred there or they
going to stay where they where they came
in so just a quick followup then so the
resources I just want to be clear that
the resources are not a patient driven
you know exercise meaning that if you
don't have the resources you can still
find a bed that you you need and yes yes
yes I I was talking of resources in
terms of beds availability
yes representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you commissioner for taking the
question in regards to following up
represent Edwards when we look at the
state
budget what do we think we have to again
as get through the budgetary process not
everything is funded by the federal
government some of it's F funded by the
state um treasury if you will state
budget is there enough money in that
process now with the current budget to
do what we need to do to meet the target
here are we looking to somehow
enhance that budget to make sure this
program's
successful no I would agree it's a it's
a combination of federal funds and
general funds and I think at this point
we're where we're leveraged is you know
obviously we're starting the budget
planning phases for for next bium and
there's are things that we're looking at
so this is money that is current that we
currently have I'm not necessarily
thinking that it's going to be a major
increase for
that any other questions for the
commissioner on this subject
any other questions for the commissioner
while she's
here I would say that as a resident of
Hamstead the more detailed
information about the YDC new building
that could be shared with Town officials
would only be for the
better um I realize as a state building
it doesn't have to be approved by the
town planning board but I think they'd
like to take a look in Greater detail at
things
um as State Rep for
Hamstead um I get a lot of calls and we
all know some of the calls are
just what they are but we also hear some
that make some sense
and I think the more
communication with both Town officials
and
citizens on the issues they are
particularly concerned about will help
the project going
forward would you like me to respond to
that only if you want to I I would agree
and I think we need to also be afforded
the opportunity to communicate we have
we have information that we have been
trying to communicate and share that I
know too haven't always been successful
so I I agree there's there's nothing to
hide here we want to be able to share
what we have and have good discussion
and um good questions on it um I think
we're we're ready for that opportunity
so and me now speaking to some folks who
aren't here there's better ways to
receive information when it's
offered sure so I'm happy to I tell
people I'm in the middle of the road and
they inform me that's where the
roadkills often f found but uh that's
other than the salary that's why I'm in
this
job so thank you but we believe in
Sharing what we have there so appreciate
that thank you anything else for the
commissioner thank you so
much and we now bring up uh Melissa
Hardy and Jessica
Gorton um
DD and ABD weight list quarterly
report welcome back good morning thank
you for having us I think you met
Jessica last time but she is our new
bureau chief at developmental services
so you'll be seeing her and hearing from
her so happy to have her on
board um as you know um and I think as
we've been reporting um ongoing at this
committee as far as the financial weight
list for DD ABD Services remains at zero
everybody who has requested funding for
services are funded um I think from this
committee the ask generally has been for
those
funded um who is getting services and at
what level of services are they
receiving those services so are they
getting half of them are they getting um
a third of those services that have been
authorized um as you know um and has
been previously stated in um other um
oversight committees uh before New
Hampshire um easy not sorry before New
Hampshire leads which was the system
that the area agencies and oursel used
before that went down that's how we
tracked a lot of that
information um I'm excited to report
we're making some progress on the on our
it side um to make up for um data and
the information that was lost during um
that uh data breach and consequently um
closing that system that we had used in
conjunction with the area agencies
before so um June 28th we're expecting a
release um from our it system that will
help um as far as identifying start
dates for each service that somebody's
authorized for um and then we'll
automate some processes that are
currently manual for service
coordinators and area agencies so
aligning um service authorizations with
dates of service will be
automatic also um we are meeting with
area agencies probably in July um to
review and reinforce their role in um
noting in the system if somebody um is
has a delay in service why is there a
delay in service so we can then pull
directly from the system to get that
data um the way we were doing it before
was manual and because of all the system
changes and strengthening it was just
it's not something that we can put on
the system right now to to continue to
track manually so that's why you see a
little bit of lack of that data as far
as um you know the reasons why Services
were authorized but not
started in the report here um you can
see that for the DD waiver this past I
think this is the second quarter so
we're talking um Quarter Two of this
fiscal year um 40 individuals were
funded for services out of those 40
individuals 17 were projected to start
those services within quarter two and
then in actuality 12 started services
with um with uh either that's receiving
full services or partial
Services as the data uh improves we're
hoping to break that down as far as full
or partial what that means um as it
relates to authorized services so um
we're we're excited for the the it
improvements and hopefully that'll help
also give this committee information as
we're um looking at um the services
provided for the DD and the ABD waiver
moving
forward um so for the in home supports
waiver we funded 12 individuals in
quarter 2 nine were projected um to
start services and out of those 97
started either receiving full or partial
Services during that quarter and then
lastly um for the ABD waiver the
acquired brain disorder waiver we had
one individual that was funded however
they chose not to start Services um in
quarter or two so they did not start
services but that was their choosing to
do
so um I think as previously discussed um
in talking with area agencies providers
service coordinators um the the
struggles are still the same as far as
Workforce um as far as limited vendor
capacity but I believe that is improving
as you know we're out there we're
providing funding um in area agencies
and and other providers are coming on
board and enrolling directly into
Medicaid to provide services I think
we'll see
um the fruits of that labor um but it's
still you know as as all agencies are
struggling with with Workforce um that
that is still the number one issue that
we hear not only from area agencies but
our providers as well that provide the
services in the community just to note
um we did previously issue 27 Workforce
grants for home and community- based
waiver Services which was about $16
million that was infused into the HCB BS
or Home and Community Based system we
recently had posted an uh an additional
Grant opportunity um and at that they
those have not been granted yet but
we're um assuming about $6.5 million do
would be appropriated again for
recruiting and retention efforts for
Home and Community Based Services so
we're hoping to see um that that has an
impact on not only recruiting people
into into the industry but also um to
retain them and move them um along you
know if they if they choose to do so
with career
opportunities there a couple other
updates if I can if you're interested um
we use a system called New Hampshire
easy um which is something that the area
agencies have used for a long time um as
far as you know getting information from
uh our department
we are currently piloting New Hampshire
easy with actual service providers in
the community so then they can see that
information that's in there without
having to go to either a service
coordinator an area agency or BDS
ourselves um kind of we're we're we're
cutting out the middleman so the
provider can directly go into the system
and see what services have been
authorized for their individuals that
they serve so that's currently in
piloting process um with with a provider
that was part of a steering committee
for
that representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for the report um so what I'm
wondering is we have the 40 new
individuals U allocated funds for the
I'm just looking at the DD waiver
um
and 17 were projected to start services
so I'm assuming that means that five are
waiting for the right Pro care provider
Workforce to come
along tell me about the other 28 people
and and where they are in the process or
what's happening with them just so I
know the other 28 people I well you've
got you've got 40 new individuals
approved for services and maybe I've
I've uh 17 have been projected to start
so
um 23 other people have been funded are
not projected to start services so where
are they in the process and what's
happening right so some of those um
individuals may start in the next
quarter so they might have been funded
for Quarter Two um but either they're
waiting for uh it could be anything it
could be waiting for exiting for school
it could be uh paperwork concerns it's
it's a myriad of of concerns or or
issues that might hold up uh even
personal choice maybe they don't want to
start Services till after summer
vacation so to speak so um and I think
looking at our data system we want to
break down that number as well so if if
if we're getting requests for funding
and we're you know we're saying we've
allocated certain you know 40 people to
be funded and only 17 have started we w
we also want to know you know um out of
those why have they not started or what
is it person Choice yeah is it personal
and I think that's part of our data
integration we want that number broken
down um where it's not a manual process
to put you know on our service
coordinators to continue to do that
right but yes that's certainly something
in another quarter we might have better
information hoping yes we're hoping that
the next time we come to you that we'll
have it might not be perfect and might
not be everything that you're looking
for but hopefully it's um more of a
breakdown of some of these numbers as to
you know if somebody was funded why did
they not start or if they started why is
it partially started thank
you representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair and thank you for the report and
also taking the question in regards to
it says 40 new
individuals two questions if I may Mr
chair one is how many people applied and
were not accepted
and then how many people we have in the
current system because the 40 is only
for new versus existing so there's two
questions how many do we have existing
that are not part of the new and how
many people who applied did not receive
approval the the second question as far
as how many people have applied and not
accepted I don't have that with me today
but I can um get that information
currently um and Jess might know how
many folks currently are being D on the
DD waiver it's somewhere in the area of
4500 individuals currently receiving
Services through the developmental
disabilities
waiver thank you thank you for that it
helps me to understand the magnitude of
what we're talking about 4500 versus 40
is kind of interesting the other one we
have the numbers about who applied it
did not receive approval is why they
didn't receive approval is trying to
understand what it is that is either a
constraint or a barrier for them um and
that something we can do legislatively
to try to minimize it thank
you might you be able to shoot the
committee an email with that yes I will
follow up thank you any other
questions and Miss Gorton I don't know
if I have your business card yet some
point because you are only part of you
is in my
phone oh sure uh pick a card any card
good thank you don't hand that to them
that's
yours thank
you I lost your phone by the way I lost
my phone so I lost your phone number I
can get that to you you're welcome just
text me I will
any other questions for the team
here here's our
Conta dark just
happened well thank you thank you how
long was it between your request for
cards and your reception of cards I'm
really digging into this
one too long is the answer
right too long I don't think is bad I
think that's not too too bad it's
getting better yes thank you let improve
it could I put that in the
minutes don't put that in the minutes
thank
you prescription drug monitoring program
annual
report Adam Burch and
wow thank
you and Mr bur if you could give us your
contact information if you have a deck
of cards to hand out or good morning I
did not bring a deck of cards with me I
will make sure to get that to everyone
yeah thank
you that I can
do good morning everyone morning I'm
Adam Birch I'm the new prescription drug
monitoring program system administrator
and I'm going to take you through a
fairly lengthy packet in as
quickly a time as I can I'm going to
point out what we think at the
prescription drug monitoring program are
the most important elements of it and
then I would be happy to answer any
questions you might
have to get things started if you would
turn to the fourth page pdmp technology
expenses I'm going to be referencing
something called Gateway a little bit
later the core pdmp system is made up of
two pieces of software the basic system
is called aware that is where all of the
prescription data is stored the other
piece is called Gateway what this allows
it it allows Physicians and pharmacist
to directly access the other system from
within their electronic health record
systems instead of having to log in
through a separate web portal uh earlier
on before my time we received feedback
that logging in was combersome and it
took way too long per patient we heard
that concern we took action to make sure
that that would no longer be a barrier
we'll see further on that this is a good
investment on our
end if you would turn to page six
highlights for State fiscal year
2023 our total registration count is
down this is primarily because of things
like retirements moving out of state or
no longer carrying a DEA license which
means that those users would not be
eligible to be connected to our
system um
despite a decrease in the number of
users the number of queries to our
system from Physicians and pharmacists
have gone up dramatically and we can
attribute a lot of that to Gateway as
you'll see just a little bit
later overall opioid prescriptions are
down year-over-year as our sedatives and
stimulants have continued to rise
year-over-year I have a little bit more
on
that if you move to page eight Gateway
integration you can see that the
overwhelming rise in the number of
queries made to our system by physicians
and pharmacists come from the Gateway
integration we have made it much easier
for the prescribers and the pharmacists
to use the pdmp and they are clearly
taking advantage of
that next if you would like to go
to page 16 days Supply an average
morphine milligram equivalent I would
just want to point this out so that
there are no concerns you'll see that
there is an aggressive and somewhat
alarming looking jump in the line on
this graph that is because CDC changed
the way milligram morphine equivalents
are calculated on that year it is not
because patients within the state of New
Hampshire are receiving dramatically
higher doses of
opioids turning over to the very next
page New Hampshire resident age at date
of opioid dispensation we can see that
opioid prescriptions are down across
every age
category um it is not that any
one portion of the state are receiving
less opioid prescriptions it is that in
every County and in every age group
people are feeling the need to use
opioid prescriptions less and we
consider this to be a good trend
and would you Al would you
also um believe that providers are being
more cautious and looking for
Alternatives I do believe that to be the
case especially if we consider that the
use of the pdmp system by providers has
been going up year overy year and we can
see the corresponding decrease in the
total uh opioid prescriptions and more
importantly a increase in the number of
people who are receiving more than 100
milligram morphine equivalent per day
those are the ones who are at the
highest risk for developing substance
use disorder down the road thank
you
question yeah could we uh jump in with
some questions on what given us so far
and then absolutely pick up from there
representative Edwards I'm just on page
two thank you Mr chair uh what what do
you know the RSA under that organized
the pdmp uh the current RSA for the pdmp
is RSA
126a um and I believe it's 89 through
starts at
87 I I didn't hear the second uh we
think it starts at 87 um and okay I can
figure it out from there uh and I'm just
I'm just having uh literary problems
this morning morning it's under data
analysis uh it says review and Analysis
or
pdmp data is is that meant to be of yes
it is okay because that was the ores
were just throwing me off all right
thank
you any other questions on the report so
far representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking the question in the
middle of the presentation um having
used the pdmp in the past in your right
it was terribly
burdensome um does the Gateway allow uh
access to the um uh to the system by a
proxy for a physician now or does it
have to be provider does it have to be
the provider it's himself or herself
doing it uh each setup is dependent on
the electronic health record system
itself but it is designed to be accessed
from right within the prescribing
portion of an electronic health record
system which means that the physician is
accessing it directly at the moment that
they are getting ready to write a
prescription followup followup um quick
followup um and I appreciate also that
the number of opioids is going down
because there was a time in the 80s and
early 990s as you remember you may
remember that was considered a fifth
Vital sign was pain so my question is
what is now used as a substitute for the
opioid opioids now that um is being used
so that patients are getting adequate
treatment uh the current best practices
recommendations it depends on the type
of pain being described so as an
example previous to my time joining the
pdmp uh the pdmp did work with the uh
New Hampshire oral health program to
distribute best practices guidelines to
dentists throughout the state uh a
combination of acetaminophen and
ibuprofen Tylenol and ibuprofen works
better after a dental procedure than
opioids do and we saw a drop in the
opioid prescriptions for normal dental
procedures where they may not be as
effective as
non-opioids thank
you representative
Weber thank you and I I just want to uh
I'm channeling representative Dr Nagle
now
um make a plea for those people
who um we occasionally hear about those
who are in chronic long-term pain cancer
patients terminal patients uh who are
and and also others living with chronic
pain um who feel that
they are not given enough options um and
I'm I'm remembering back when my late
husband was U had metastatic bone
disease back in the late
80s um he could have hot and cold
running
msir and and chose that route rather
than Ms conton because he could control
how much he had in his system at any
time and so we were at that point able
to have a very large supply of very lowd
dose pills in our house and I don't know
if that's the case anymore but um and
and I'm not sure that you delve into
that aspect of things from where you sit
which is really monitoring the
flow uh but have you been hearing
anything about issues of
people genuine needing and and not being
able to receive dosages that are um
necessary for them we have not been
notified of any substantial problems
across the state for the people who do
need the opioid prescriptions to control
chronic pain they do seem to still be
getting them what we are seeing is
mostly a decrease in
opioid in high risk
prescribing and that is mostly the ones
that we're concerned with right thank
you representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair and also thank you for the report
it's well documented well done in
regards to I think by if I understand it
correctly the data comes from the
pharmacies themselves when they dispense
the medication to a patient so that's
all been by the RSA required to be
reported to somewhere but my question is
within somewhere within the department
where does that data get
parked that data is received by the uh
the core aware software that our vendor
provides for us and that is where it
lands that is where it stays so I so the
data is not internal to New Hampshire
it's actually within the vendor that is
correct okay thank
you representative Edwards with a
followup to representative Merchant's
question so so I'm really very
interested in
um collecting the data storing the data
analyzing the data that uh and sharing
the data with other interested parties
like for example the Department of
Insurance also collects a lot of data on
Pharmaceuticals and so and and the
prescription drug affordability board
has a similar requirement so my my
thought on this is we seem to have
different uh data collection efforts
that are possible um it
or does does the core aware software
also do those as a service do they do
the uh analysis and Reporting and
queries for you uh they do provide us
with a tableau instance where our data
analyst can go in and look at aggregate
data um it is important to note that our
analyst is not digging into personally
identifiable data we do aggregate
analysis um when it comes to access to
personally identifiable data that is
limited specifically to the Physicians
and pharmacists that access that's good
I wasn't asking about privacy but but
thank you does that data analyst
employed by the state or or that's a
state employee doing the data anal
analyst is a state employee the Tableau
dashboards that have been set up for us
are set up by the vendor and we have the
ability to make our own as well all
right outstanding thank
you all right you may continue your
report all
right is if you would turn to the top
pdmp user roles and patient request
activity uh 1 2 3 4 5
6 12 18 uh 18
24 30 uh
five my apologies mine are condensed and
not numbered so I have to count as I go
along uh what you can see is that at
this moment we are still in a phase
where most of the queries are being run
by delegates for prescribers uh at this
time slightly less than 30% of all of
the uh healthc care facilities in the
state that could Connect using Gateway
are on board with it that is an ongoing
effort on our part we are continuing to
work facility by facility to get them
connected so that that way the
Physicians are the ones who are using it
most often
uh speaking to data sharing uh if you
go one two three four five uh six pages
forward we have a slide on data sharing
these are the states that we have
Interstate data sharing agreements with
uh what this means is that prescribers
and pharmacists in those states are also
able to query our system that way if we
have New Hampshire residents that uh
spend a portion of their year in another
state their Physicians have access to
complete
records if I may
Mr Mr
chair clar clarification question on the
data when it's going into the
vendor because we have strict privacy
laws in the state of New Hampshire
what's to ensure that if the data is
going to another state that that state
is not getting into Data that we have on
our patients if you will are they
following and how do they do this follow
our state law so that our state law is
not
being bypassed if you will when it gets
to another state thank you for the
question uh the way an interstate data
access works is we first have to
determine that the state that we have an
interstate data sharing agreement with
has security measures in place to make
sure that only authorized us users that
would be able to access our system if
they were New Hampshire prescribers or
pharmacists are allowed to make those
Interstate queries uh none of the data
from our system goes into those other
state systems it is held completely
within our own and it is only the
authorized users that if they were New
Hampshire licensed Physicians or
pharmacists uh that are accessing
it representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you again taking the
question um number one do you know if uh
DH is using the DH System is using the
Gateway uh product and the other
question is is this dependent upon the
electronic health record that they use
as to whether or not they can access
Gateway meaning many of them are on Epic
right now is that epic compatible with
Gateway right now epic is compatible
each installation of Epic is slightly
different and each one has to be
configured one at a time but epic all
Epic installations are capable of making
a Gateway integration at this time
Dartmouth is not yet connected through
Gateway um that is an ongoing
process
followup you you led me down this road
yourself uh what is what do you mean by
this process an ongoing process a
portion of Dartmouth is connected the
pharmacy within Dartmouth is connected
through Gateway um the main hospital so
Physicians practicing within Dartmouth
are not yet
connected Vox clant in
deserto yeah go ahead is there a reason
why they are
not that is an excellent
question the initial funding that
covered
Gateway uh ended in the at the end of
September of this year and the source of
funding that we applied to to follow on
to that was not guaranteed our ability
as the state to cover the cost of
Gateway was not assured until after we
received the award um if you flip I know
it's going to send you all the way back
to the beginning pretty much uh if you
flip to page five the pdmp is fully
federally funded we get two funding
sources uh one is the overdose data to
action Grant which put a uh funding
limitation on how much pdmps were
allowed to receive from that and the
other one is the Harold Rogers
prescription drug monitoring program
grant that 2-year funding source is
competitive slightly less than half of
all states in the nation received it
this year um without both of those we
would not be able to cover the costs of
Gateway which would mean prescribers or
facilities would have to cover the costs
themselves that was the way the previous
uh contract with our vendor was written
with the in mind that we were going to
pursue uh funding to continue supplying
it for those users we were awarded the
funds and the contract amendment was
approved by governor and Council so
there were a number of facilities that
were waiting to see what was going to
happen in terms of
funding maybe Dartmouth could make a
contribution you think perhaps okay
can't speak for them though right okay
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair and also thank you for the uh the
information on the cost of the program
going back through a page four when I
look at the technology expenses that I
think only refers to the technology is
there other expenses within the program
and if there are how are they funded
there are other expenses to the program
we have four staff members myself uh our
Pharmacy auditor our data analyst and
our uh Administrative Assistant uh they
are also covered by those two Federal
funding
sources follow up so looking at it being
competitive what happens if we don't
have the federal grants are we going
back to the state treasury to find out
how to support the program I'm just
looking down the road and saying come
2025 there's a termination on those
grants um is there any thought in the
budgetary process going forward to what
to do to offset the loss of those
grants for uh that is something that we
keep track of internally at all times it
is top of mind every day um at the end
of this two-year funding period there is
an expectation that there will be a new
two-year funding opportunity we are
anticipating applying for it at this
time um if we were to be limited to only
one of the two current funding sources
we would not be able to continue paying
for a gateway directly and we have
explored options for how to cover the
cost for that
in in a meaningful
way please
continue uh the last thing that I would
like to point out is oh got to count
again uh 6 12
3 35 34 uh page 32 uh prescription
auditing error type and severity
um when it comes to any data system the
ability to rely on what's inside of that
data system relies entirely on the
quality of the data coming in through
the tireless efforts of our uh of our
Pharmacy auditor Leslie Pond we can say
with a high degree of certainty that
when a physici accesses our system they
are getting accurate information in
return we have an above 99% data
accuracy
rate and that is all I have good thank
you so
much and do we have your
2022 New Hampshire Suicide Prevention
report Amy Cook Suicide Prevention
project manager for Nami and Jenny
ohiggins senior policy an analyst
division for Bureau Behavioral Health
and Katherine M Cox administrator
division for Behavioral Health
DHHS and yet only one m
microphone we can share does everyone
have a copy of the slides Senator gray I
don't know if
you excellent you printed it out in
color it
looks yeah does anyone not have
one we have
extras good thank you okay
great
okay so good morning thank you for
allowing us to share with you today
about this new report that we just
published um my name is Amy Cook I'm the
chair of the suicide prevention Council
I'm employed at Nami New Hampshire here
in conquer and work with their Suicide
Prevention team prior to that um I you
may recognize my face from leading the
division of community-based military
programs at the department of military
Affairs and veteran
services uh so today I'm here as you
mentioned with Jenny and Catherine do
you want to do an in hi I'm Katherine
Cox I'm the Statewide Suicide Prevention
coordinator with the division for
Behavioral
Health and I'm Jenny O
Higgins I'm a senior po policy analyst
in Behavioral Health as well and our
legislatively is on for our division
which is the role I'm here today in
excellent so the main purpose of today's
presentation is to share some highlights
from that report that full report that
you all have uh suicide prevention is an
important public health issue demanding
a really comprehensive and multifaceted
approach to make a meaningful impact
addressing this pervasive challenge
necessitates an approach that goes
beyond just mental health counseling so
it requires a broad array of services
that span Mental Health Care Community
Support education and a lot of Outreach
initiatives but the most important
message that we try to get out as the
suicide prevention council is that there
is Hope and suicide is generally
preventable so collaboration you'll
notice is throughout that entire report
especially in the first many pages uh
collaboration between healthc care
providers Educators policy makers
Community leaders is essential to create
a unified front against a Public Health
Challenge so it emphasizes the need for
ongoing research policy development and
resource allocation to truly make a
difference in the lives of New Hampshire
residents so I'm going to jump into um
the slides that we have in this packet
here um in the beginning before we talk
about sort of data and trends that we
found I just want to make sure um that
you have information about how the
council who the council is who it's made
up of and how it operates so on that
first page um you'll see that the
council's dedicated to promoting
awareness that suicide is a preventable
public health problem and together we
can raise awareness increase access to
mental health substance misuse and
Suicide Prevention Services
legislatively the council is mandated to
oversee implementation of the New
Hampshire Suicide Prevention plan which
is renewed every 5 years on the next
page you'll see
membership um the council is made up of
24 statutory members that represent a
diverse spectrum of stakeholders engaged
in suicide vention efforts including
Health Care Systems nonprofits city
state federal government and individuals
who have lived experience with not only
suicide attempts but also suicide
law the next page shows just an overview
of our leadership the rsas that
established the council require a chair
a vice chair and a clerk to lead the
council and then recently we also
created a position for treasurer to
assist with effective use of available
funds the SPC is administratively tied
to DHHS and benefits from their
professional
guidance next is committees on that
following page and this is really where
the heart of the council truly resides
it's within the work of these committees
we currently have six Active committees
plus a conference uh planning work group
so statutory members and also others who
are not uh statutory members of of the
council contribute to the committee's
work so just a couple examples of things
that the Committees have accomplished um
our Communications committee spent all
of 2023 standing up a website for The
Suicide Prevention Council which is now
publicly available and sharing
information uh our survivors of suicide
loss committee holds multiple events
throughout the year for those who are
who are on their own journey of healing
public policy committee is an instrument
in helping to educate not only our
council members but others about issues
that impact Suicide Prevention in the
past two years the military and veterans
committee has focused on engaging
Community providers in military culture
training and suicide prevention training
and they've tracked
1,575 hours of training taken by
Community providers as a specific result
of their efforts and the first responder
committee hosts annual school resource
officer conference to support their work
with atrisk youth the conference
planning workg group is currently
preparing for the 21st annual Suicide
Prevention Conference next year um or
this coming November so that's attended
every year by about 200 to 300
individuals across the state the next
slide jumps into the actual report uh
the suicide the The Suicide Prevention
council is required to produce this
annual report outlining the status of
Suicide Prevention work across New
Hampshire as well as Trends found in the
latest confirmed data the data helps
inform which populations age groups are
most at risk reveals points of
particular particular vulnerability and
then helps guide prevention and
intervention efforts sources of data
include Vital Records data for the State
of New Hampshire and the national
violence death reporting system and more
details in the full report around page 2
7 it goes into quite extensive detail
about the sources of data so as you may
be aware it's important to note that
there's always a lag in confirmed data
um the CDC for example takes several
months to collect data um then confirm
it compile it and release it so because
of that delay most of the data found in
the 2022 report that you have is
reflective of
2021 it's also important to note that
the report is really only a snapshot
granted it's a very comprehensive
snapshot um but it's nearly impossible
to capture and catalog every instance or
program aimed at Suicide Prevention in
the state the elements are on the next
page just really quickly gives you sort
of a lay of the land for what's in the
report and how to navigate it it's 91
pages long so it is really
comprehensive great I get to kick us off
with some of the key points that were
you know rising to the top from our data
committee who compiles this report for
us annually um so this is all available
to you in the infographic that was a
companion document uh that you should
all have in front of you so you can
follow along with the slides or you can
look at the infographic as I go through
um so right at the top of that there
were in 2021 229 individuals who died by
suicide in New
Hampshire and it is the second leading
cause of death ages 15 to 34 it's the
10th leading cause of death overall
across all ages some folks are
interested in how the suicide rate
compares to the homicide rate um so
suicides outnumber homicides in the US
and uh the same is true over New
Hampshire where there are 12 suicides
for every
homicide and uh the last figure on this
slide is that of all firearm deaths 89%
of them are from suicide or intentional
self
harm in the US this number is closer to
about
66% the next page shows uh really
focuses on some of the geography and
locations in New Hampshire and we like
to look at Trends here to determine
where in the state we might Infuse
additional resources Suicide Prevention
or postvention training or awareness
campaigns so you'll see the the uh
picture that you see there shows that
we're really New Hampshire at a
16.06 suicide rate is in the middle of
the range seen across all New England
states uh at a county level which you
can see in the full report we are able
to learn that Coos County experienced
the highest suicide rate in 20 uh 21 in
straford County experience the lowest
I'm I'm having trouble tracking you what
what what what page is the map with the
counties that is in the full report so
in the 91 page full report I can get you
the exact page though and I have an
extra copy if you would like to look at
it I'll flip through it okay great
figure 14 page on page
[Laughter]
32 is that online as well and if so
could you send us a link to it yeah
absolutely because that probably is the
easiest way for many of us to get a hold
of it yep
absolutely so um on this next page where
really focusing on the adult data and so
fatality data is really only one part of
the picture when we're thinking about
suicidality in New Hampshire and so um
The Human Experience just is incredibly
complex and so human lives are filled
with grief and loss and pain um so these
figures really show that um there were
about 52,000 adults overall who had
thoughts of suicide and then there were
about 3,500 adults who attempted suicide
and so really thinking about you know
trying to get more Upstream to to Really
Provide support for those in um in need
it's not that people want to die it's
that they just want their pain to end
and so um a couple of the additional
things is that my job is really to take
this information and then to put it into
to programs and make improvements on
existing things it's noted that
affordability and accessibility are two
of the key barriers for people who want
to access you know timely Mental Health
Care um when they need it so there's a
couple of efforts that I just wanted to
point out in relation to this data the
first regarding affordability is that
there is a study commission currently
going on S sp85 that's related to the
sustainability of Crisis
services in addition there's been some
crisis system transformation to reduce
barriers to accessing crisis Services
when a person needs it and where they
need it that's through our rapid
response access point and 988 that was
the national three-digit number that's
been released we really are hoping to
encourage folks to call early and call
often when they are in their time of
need and also we're really trying to
shift culture around defining what
culture is it's really defined by the
individual and so we want them to call
us when they are feeling overwhelmed or
um like really struggling so that they
um can get access earlier on and not
only think think that they can access
those Services when they're in a
suicidal
crisis the next page is regarding youth
specifically so this is um taken from
our ybs data and looking broadly across
all students um 9.8 so almost 10% of
students overall um indicated that they
had made a suicide attempt one or more
times question in yes yeah go ahead
representative which I I was going to
wait for you to take a breath there but
I'm curious about the students uh who
are prone to um suicide
ideation um is is there has there been
any research to
correlate um those that are most at risk
with the presence of two parent
families my my theory is that a student
that's in a two parent family is
probably less likely to have the
depression and the and the concerns that
can feed and the pain that can feed a
mental illness um and I'm just curious
if that's something you all look into so
we can get to root causes and not just
symptoms so I don't know if this mic is
fully reaching me over here but um I do
we do specifically look at risk and
protective factors and those include
individual risk factors some of which
are fixed such as you know genetics just
like with any other health condition and
others of which are variable and that's
where we believe we can really make the
most um prevention intervention work and
so we look at those adverse childhood
experiences and adverse community
experiences and those include um to
their to your point more specific
question they they have things to do
with parental risk as well if a parent
is incarcerated if their the family has
experienced divorce if a parent has uh
experience depression that those are
things that can increase risk factors
and that having that information about
our families that we're serving and the
students in the schools and things like
that allow us to then be responsive to
the type of prevention or intervention
we can offer we can offer that Universal
prevention that's for everyone but we
can also offer prevention that is either
selected people that have more risk
factors or indicated those who are
actually already showing
risk representative King thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you for this is
just a continuation of that just going a
little deeper into the root
cause um I work pretty closely with a
Recovery Center in Milford New Hampshire
and um what we find with addiction uh
substance use disorder is uh isolation
has a lot to do with how people feel
about themselves and then uh there was a
report last June and uh that was was
about social media and the effects on
how uh these kids feel about themselves
and actually probably even adults um so
how does that fall into some of the
things that you look at yeah these are
great questions they are speaking to
some of those additional respector when
we talked earlier about the county
differences as well as the geographic
differences throughout the United States
and sort of where New Hampshire falls it
does speak directly to some of the
pieces around isolation access to
Behavioral Healthcare um Workforce
shortages in these in these regions
access to lethal means in certain areas
and regions and so you see those risk
and protective Factor factors change
based on where we live and while social
media is complex and could probably be
its entire own meeting if not multiple
um it it can contribute to isolation so
there are times when people are engaging
in social media and creating connection
and there are other uses of it that
don't allow you to build relationships
and so it's really not necessarily how
much time are we spending but what are
we doing when we are
engaging representative Edwards uh thank
you Mr chair um the the the the the
question got me interested in um um the
governor's executive order I think it
was maybe eight months ago or so um
trying to um discourage social media use
amongst kids 14 years or younger I
forget exactly what that tradeoff was or
that that timeline was but um uh do do
do we think that social media um and
Adolescence is um basically um a a a
Channel or a
contagion that sort of propagates the
the concerns that feed suicide ideation
do do do we have any correlation between
access and use of social media to the
propensity to have suicide
ideation so again such a complex topic
but I think it it it does both things
where it social media can be a place to
identify students at risk and get them
the help that they need and be able to
intervene it can also be a place to make
sure to send out resources and sort of
promote things like call 988 if you're
at risk so you can use it as a
prevention tool as well but if there is
increased um bullying or people are
facing victimization or discrimination
they are then also at increased risk so
it's a both things can be true situation
and what we need to do is really Empower
Our Youth and make sure that they're
educated on what that looks like and how
it impacts
them I'm looking at the uh percentages
of all students who feel sad and
hopeless and I want to break out sad
it's like whenever my wife was a doctor
says what's your pain level and I said
it's 10 she says why it's mine and of
other people uh less subjective might
say my pain is actually a four so how do
you deal with the question of what is
sad yes so the youth RIS Behavior survey
is qualitative so it's it's based on how
that student what that student believes
to when they feel sad or hopeless it's
it's identifying simply that they have
felt sad and hopeless within the time
period in which they're asked however
they would Define what that means so it
gives us a sense while those things may
be so different on our scale if we had
Stu two students in front of us who both
answered yes to that question one may be
going through significant family trauma
had a recent loss something that we feel
like is a really challenging and another
may have had a recent breakup that we
would say hey plenty of fish in the sea
right so it's not about how we look at
what's going on with those students it's
about how they perceive their pain and
do you have a longitudinal marker on
this such as depression has to be
certain amount of time before it's
really considered clinical depression
um how about sadness everybody's sad I'm
I'm surprised the number isn't 100% yeah
yeah so the way that that question is
worded is sad or hopeless for a period
of time over the like for a period of
longer than two weeks over the last
month something like that and I can't
remember the exact language but happy to
email it to you as well the way that the
question is worded okay good thank you
counselor uh representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair in looking
at the overall data one of the things
that's really catching my eye is the
disparity between
gender and it's not slight it's in my
opinion
pronounced can you kind of speak to why
it's so pronounced what's sort of
driving that and also the other question
is when I look at the states that are in
the higher above average by the US it
seems to be states that have more of a
rural population but I'm trying to find
the map just look at it is more
prevalent in Rural America than it is in
urban America so the two questions is
number one why is there such a gender
gap and then number two is there a
geographical one as
well want me to take them sure okay so
gender we tend to see in both nationally
and in New Hampshire that fatality is
higher amongst men and that making
suicide attempts is higher amongst
females and so what that tells us is
that what we're here really to talk
about is prevention and so we have many
many more people have thoughts of
suicide you know many many people
everybody to um your point earlier is
everyone feels sad or hopeless at times
but there is a smaller number of people
who experience suicidal ideation right
have thoughts of suicide and even
smaller number of those folks will make
a plan and even smaller number of the
people who make a plan will make an
attempt and of those who make an attempt
an even smaller number will will
actually have a a um die by Suicide and
so therefore what that tells us is that
there's a a lot of points for prot
potential intervention or to do good
prevention to prevent those fatalities
and so what we see with those numbers
for for females is that we have a lot of
potential intervention and that what we
know about the means by which people die
and are more likely to have to
experience fatality is that males tend
to choose more lethal means and so
there's less of opportunity for an
intervention and to save that a life and
so we look at policy that puts time
and distance between a person in crisis
and access to highly lethal
means and can you speak to the follow up
please thank you can you speak to the
issue about geographic forgot it while I
was um just going on and on about the
first one so the other question about
geography you'll see both yes to your
question about is does it tend to be
higher in rural areas of both the
country and the state and then what what
we understand about some of those
differences include
oftentimes Workforce shortages and less
Economic Opportunity that can lead to
hopelessness we also socioeconomic
disparity lack of access to health care
including behavioral mental health
substance use disorder treatment
services firearm ownership is often
higher which is the most lethal means of
suicide um and housing instability food
instability all of these things kind of
come back to when we were talking about
those risk and protective factors so
when we see those higher risk factors
and the lower protective factors which
also include connectedness is a
protective factor and so that isolation
is
concerning thank you please
continue I don't know where I left off
um I feel like we've through discussion
I think we've like concluded our
conversation about the slide that I was
on other than just there's a note to to
on this slide about the increased
percentage of um um for students who
identify as LGB lgbq and latinx that
those are higher percentages for those
key demographics that were um surveyed
in the ybs so we keep an eye on efforts
that specifically address those needs of
those children in our
state representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman and um
thank you for the work that you do and
presenting this information to us um you
all sit with a very broad smile on your
face
and my experience over time is that
these numbers have increased
substantially and I'm looking at
particularly at the students and the
kids and there was recently a a couple
dartman students have just passed away
and as you well aware of so I don't have
to go through the history but it is
depressing to me to watch the trend line
so my question is not a specific
question about the data and who is doing
it and why how do you protect yourselves
from um becoming impacted negatively
with this
information I'll go first um I think
what the reason coming here is such a
good opportunity to to highlight what
the breadth of Suicide Prevention work
to include the comp compilation of this
data to help inform the that information
but just the membership of the council
the activities of the council can really
produce a lot of Hope there are pockets
of Excellence of community and sense of
belongingness and training and education
and awareness building that are
happening around the state and so while
we're here talking about you know the
fatality data that you know can really
be striking and and you know um alarming
and I think it's really important to
also root Eng ground ourselves in the
foundation of hope that our that our
state has really um supported Suicide
Prevention along the way and it's
through Partnerships um like presenting
here with Amy
um and being able to talk with you all
about some of the complicated nature of
suicidality as it presents and also to
highlight some of the efforts that we're
trying to
do and I would add to that you know uh
the human component of looking out for
each other in connection and I've seen
an increase in that um among
professionals over the past five or six
years I think we get so caught up in the
populations that we're looking at and
the programs um and we so I'm also
co-chair of our military and veterans
committee for this Council and have been
for many years and we had sort of a
moment where we had to really look at
how we were supporting each other one of
our own um members of that committee um
died by suicide last year and we thought
of all people who knew the
resources you know he was on the
committee we talk about this every time
we meet so we really started to have
conversations around the table of how
are we caring for each other and how are
we looking out for each other and so
little even things like so we all
exchanged um you know phone numbers so
even just text messages once a week you
know it's no we kind of have these group
check-ins of like Hey how do you like
the weather this week you know even just
those little reach out um T just
Connection in general so I've seen a lot
of things like that happen not only here
in New Hampshire among professional
groups but across the country as well
because I mean Healthcare it sounds like
you're in the healthcare field um from
some of the comments you've made I mean
that again is an area where they just
have to look out for each other
yeah thank you for the work that you do
thank you so thank you so much for your
question I think that's what it's all
about is actually checking in with one
another um I think also no one just sort
of falls into this work so many of us
and you probably assume that most people
that are involved in behavioral health
or Suicide Prevention have experienced
losses of their own or are a person with
lived experience and so for me come to
the work because what is the New
Hampshire that I want my kids to grow up
in what do I want them to know and what
do and so it's aspirational right it's
where it's to I want to live in a state
where we make connections and not
judgments and my you know kindergartener
stood up in her classroom and said when
you need police fire or ambulance you
call 911 and when you're sad angry or
feeling over overwhelmed you call 988
and when 5-year-olds tell each other
that we're making a
difference any further questions
representative
Weber well I think this is kind of a
follow-up to this question and also to
representative Edward's question about
the social media um I'm thinking about a
couple of interactions I had with
teenage
girls um over the last couple of years
and um the social media thing which for
those of us who are dinosaurs is really
mindboggling because the conversation I
was having
was can you imagine that I am not
allowed to use my social media after
11:00 at night and the first words that
came to my mind was when I was in your
age I was home at 5: and the door shut
and the telephone was supervised by my
parents and I made made myself not say
any of
that
but part I mean it seems to me that it
goes both ways I mean part of what she
was trying to tell me is I have to have
access to my phone at 3:00 in the
morning because one of my friends might
need me at 3:00 in the morning
and sorting it seems to me that it's
much more difficult today to sort out
the questions of
um yeah it's great for you to be there
for your friend it's also really not
appropriate for you to never sleep which
is one of the results and not sleeping
is one of those things it's a real risk
factor so I wonder just if if if you um
could enlighten me a little bit if you
know about work that's done around that
kind of issue because it's it's both a
support and a
real risk taker quite aside from the
amplification of the nastiness that I
got away from by getting home and
closing my front door and you know the
nastiness follows the unkind I should
say unkindness that yeah happens um
follows kids everywhere and is
inescapable at this point my social
world ended when the lights when the
street lights came on I was due to be
home um I one an example I want to share
with you that I think speaks to exactly
what you're talking about and helps in
that area um at Nami New Hampshire we do
a youth leader connect training and we
do it all across New Hampshire but we do
it in other states as well one of my
colleagues was just in Alaska working in
high schools doing this training and
what so we train youth leaders and their
adult um counterparts in school
districts to go out and be messagers
with within their school um all about
suicide prevention how to deal with
those types of issues and one example we
give the the students um is the example
of quicksand so we say if you have a
friend who is you know sinking in
quicksand um and we we get up and we
sort of role play you know what would
you do and so they all you know grab on
and and the whole point of this activity
in the end is that you know you learn
that if just you by yourself are going
to help that person who is sinking in
quicksand you're going to get pulled
into so as you were talking about the
young woman who at 3:00 in the morning
has to help her friend it made me think
immediately of that quicksand analogy
where you alone are trying to help
you're going to be pulled into um so we
really teach the youth that there are
other resources that 988 people in the
school people in the community we teach
them that you always look for a trusted
adult to help you in that situation we
teach them that 988 you can call if
you're not the one in crisis you as a
friend or you as a family member you can
call and say I have a concern about
somebody and I don't know what to do
about it um so we teach them a lot of
different things so that they're whether
it's 3:00 am or whether it's 3 pm they
start to really think about the fact
that I don't have to do this by myself
it's not just all up to me um and
there's a lot you know I'm just super
proud of the Nami New Hampshire training
so I I brag about that one but there's a
lot of trainings just like that thank
you folks so much we have another
presentation to follow on after yours uh
counselor I have your cell phone number
unless you've moved from
617 okay thank you I'm not outing you
and I did live in Greater Boston once
but the other to folks uh you're not in
my phone and maybe we would like to be
able to uh get in touch with you if you
could let us all yes email us your
contact information thank you so much
for your time thank you and last a
subcommittee of this committee uh brain
health Alzheimer's disease related
dementia quarterly report Wendy ultman
bureau chief and Jessica
esand for the senior public policy
manager Alzheimer's Association
Massachusetts in the hamsher
chapter
welcome good morning uh for the record
uh Wendy Alman bureau chief for the
Bureau of elderly and Adult
Services good morning um Mr chair
members of the committee Jessica escalin
uh senior public policy
manager closer senior public policy
manager with the Alzheimer's Association
um and I will kick us off I know Wendy
has a bit more of a substantive
presentation to give you I wanted to
provide a quick update on the
legislative subcommittee on Alzheimer's
and other dementia which I'm pleased to
report has been meeting monthly uh
continuing to solicit input about
services and um availability of those
services and awareness and really the
experience of those living with
Alzheimer's and other dementia as well
as their families and caregivers and
support networks in New Hampshire uh so
we've been continuing to solicit
multi-disciplinary information really
trying to look at where the needs lie
what is working well what um could be
improved upon and what could inform
policy in the future so uh continuing to
to pull together those presentations and
get that
information um I'm happy to answer any
questions but we're just sort of
plugging along I'm happy to happy to
report
well thank you
all right with no questions I'm just
going to move into um I have a handout
um it's has the title on it uh Pinnacle
and that is a overview of our
Alzheimer's disease and related dementia
public awareness campaign vendor that
the department is working with um this
vendor's contract was approved on May
1st and we K had a kickoff meeting in um
earlier this month on May 9th um this
included uh representation from the
subcommittee and the allers association
as well as other legislatively mentioned
and mandated uh stakeholders including
our state Commission on Aging where we
had the chair of the Commission on Aging
and the executive director as well as um
individuals from the Department
including our Communications Department
um and um individuals within the bureau
um providing input um to this kickoff
meeting so uh the handout that I
provided to you is really just an
overview of who our vendor is um and uh
the work that we plan on doing um over
the next few months uh in terms of of
information gathering um doing a uh
survey and then working with um the
community including uh individuals who
or family members with Alzheimer's
disease or related dementia providers
and others uh based on the outline of
the of the work that we need to do as
part of the legislation and the
appropriated
funds representative
Edwards so I I barely remember hb2 but I
think I remember talking to you all and
as as I so I'm going to set this up and
have you correct me if I'm mistaken okay
I I I think what we did was that within
DHHS there was a a public education
function that I think reported into Miss
Tilly I it used to report into you right
and and we set your program up as sort
of a parallel effort because we needed
these materials pretty badly and and
that the existing Public Health
capability wanted the help and needed
the help so we set you up as an
independent project to really get this
done and my concern at the time was uh
let's go ahead and get that done but I'd
like to see in the next budget cycle the
integration of the public health efforts
and not replication of multiple Public
Health efforts throughout the department
could is if that if that sounds right to
you could you tell me where we're
trending towards making sure that in the
coming budget there's one Public Health
Organization on DHHS and that your
materials will become part of that
unified effort
um certainly um within public health and
I I would defer to um associate
commissioner Tilly if she has something
to add to this um but we closely connect
with Public Health in terms of the work
and products that they put out um in
terms of prevention and messaging so we
will be partnering with them now that
the we have a vendor and we will be
working with them um to develop those
materials so in the long term we intend
to streamline and um weave in whatever
um work um and messaging that we would
be doing in terms of brain health um
Alzheimer's disease and related dementia
on the public health side um with this
campaign that that helps but M Mr chair
can can we get just get Miss Tilly to
respond to that I'm I'm would you
respond to that I'm I'm looking for um
the issue that that about whether or not
we're trending towards having a unified
department and budget that does the
comprehensive mailu of materials that we
want sure so thank you so much again for
the record Patricia Tilly ass
commissioner always happy to be here
always happy to be here with Wendy um so
what I would suggest is that we have
some work populationbased work that
happens in public health but the real
bulk of it is really sitting within
Wendy's shop right now so we are you
know the way I would frame it is we are
working in partnership with this group
um because of the work that they're
doing across the board in aging and this
fits best in that environment so again
we're malleable we know that the
resources are really within the Aging
plan and within the other work around
Alzheimer's and brain health we're here
to be supportive from a populationbased
level um to encourage that work and
ensure that whatever comes out of our
office is in alignment with them is
there anything you'd want to add to that
no great well follow follow up okay so I
I don't remember them all but the other
one that comes to mind is there was a
special initiative in Lyme disease a
while ago because we realized that we
were you know underpowered in what we
were saying about Lyme disease and so
I'm just concerned about putting these
Pockets around the department and and
not having kind of a a a coordinated
unified approach to public messaging
sure you know I I think that's always a
you know the department is enormous as
we all know that it's got a thousand
different moving parts and I actually
see that as the role of the leadership
within the department you know certainly
under the guidance of the commissioner
but also that's why you've got these
three associate Commissioners in who
have their finger in the pie in lots of
places and it's our job to make sure
that it all ties up and it coordinates
at the end of the
day so to answer your question there's
always going to be you know um I don't
expect Wendy alman's group to be you
know the experts in Lyme disease um or
the impact on um brain health in that
but we bring our partnership to them and
we work together and we develop those
relationships internally and also even
among our external Partners as well to
make sure that we're in alignment that's
90% of the the work that myself and
other my colleagues do is to make sure
that we're in alignment across the
department sometimes we miss things but
really that's what we're working towards
is that we're getting messaging out um
that the services are aligned and we've
got the resources with the right skill
sets thank you representative
Merchant and thank you Mr chair and also
thank you for taking the question when I
look at the page two going down about
the full launch and dissemination of
information
to the community at large what I don't
see there is what I think is a
relatively High touch point for a lot of
these patients is the pharmacy Community
um I worked with a endocrinologist at
dmouth recently to help to launch a
awareness campaign using Community
Pharmacy as a way to get out bone health
but I'm trying to get through why
Pharmacy because it's such a high touch
point the frequency and so forth of many
of these patients why they're not
included uh certainly uh we've only had
one uh kickoff meeting with our
stakeholder group and they currently are
providing feedback to um the onepage
summary that you see here as well as
some initial documents that are related
to um communicating out about the survey
um and who the survey needs to be
targeted to so I certainly will take
that feedback uh back to our vendor um
and I do believe that uh individuals who
are part of the Alzheimer's disease and
related dementia subcommittee which is
meeting next Wednesday will have a
chance to we you know weigh in and
provide some feedback and we do have
somebody from um the medical society who
is um sitting on that subcommittee so we
will definitely be um engaging them in
that discussion and they have a lot of
um connections and uh strategies that
will help make the campaign more robust
and I believe that that would include
Pharmacy thank
you any further
questions
is part of your plan that there may be
some suggested legislation that we would
file this fall or not I'm not begging
for work but I'm just wondering
I'm happy to answer that so certainly um
part of the legislative charge of the
subcommittee is to review all of these
various aspects of the States's response
um and the current landscape of
Alzheimer's and other Dementia in the
state and based on that survey really to
if it's prudent come forward with
legislative uh suggestions based on
again what's working what exists is need
and we do we are very fortunate to have
representative Lon and Senator avard um
spearheading the committee um and C are
very thoughtful about anything that
would be a good fit for legislation in
the future so there's no specific plan
right now I won't speak for them none
that has been communicated to me uh for
an initiative legislatively but that is
certainly Something That We're bearing
in mind as we're getting this
information I would beg you that when
legislators come to you or you go to
them about a bill to be filed have those
people coordinate with each other and
the reason is of the 75,000 bills that
were filed last
fall numbers of them were were so
similar but we had a deal with them all
it would be much better if when you meet
legislators who are hoping to help in
this you get them to coordinate with
each other yes that would certainly be
part of any strategy or conversation I
would be a part of absolutely thank you
so much
yes saying nothing further thank thank
you so much and uh we will be meeting on
um I lost my program here but we will be
meeting the fourth Friday of next month
at 10 o'clock and I'm going to key in to
um representative Weber's statement that
come September there'll be some
reorganization and times and me sorry
not nov November the the new I was
refering sorry I was referring to the
new legislator we're just very much at
the end of the system so am I right in
thinking that our next meeting is going
to be the 28th of J uh oh no I'm in July
sorry uh 1 2 3 4 28th of J 28th of June
is what um yeah so okay I just to let
you know I won't be here I'll be in DC
appreciate that and we will try to make
sure that as we reorganize in November
we do the very best we can to avoid
overlapping with other important commit
anticipating representative
Merchant just to uh confirm for July and
August there will be no meeting correct
thank you you may meet if you wish but I
won't be meeting sure yeah okay thank
you we are
adjourned for